see that
a lot of unusual specifics in this case
the amount of money made the family
history but does this ruling mean that
in future if one partner or the other
does better after a divorce
the loser can go back to court and try
and get some more money potentially it
does and the key point that comes out of
this ruling today is that there is no
time limit for bringing claims after a
divorce
and very often people forget that and
they think that if they for example
apply for their diy divorce online
that's the end of it without realizing
that sting in the tail um however what
the ruling doesn't do today is actually
make a substantive award to ms wyatt and
that's a point that really mustn't be
lost in all of this all that the uh
supreme court has said is effectively
you get passed go you can now go to the
high court and they can determine the
merits of your claim and they've also
given a very strong indication that
there are there are limits to what she
can get but on the other hand he didn't
say you might go back and get nothing i
mean from the view of the supreme court
you should get something just not nearly
two million queer yes i think the words
a comparatively modest award uh were
used and certainly that they're nearly
two talked about
his house which is absolutely so and
that would be really uh justified by
reference to that the contributions that
it said she made during the marriage but
after the marriage in bringing up the
two children now does this clash with
the other recent rulings we've had of a
judge telling a wife to get a job and it
wasn't the obligation of her husband in
this case that could have been the other
way around to go on supporting him not
sure it necessarily clashes but the
point here is very much that one needs
to bear in mind the possibility of
coming back i think the anxiety i had
had as a practitioner of speaking to
people before the ruling came out is
ensuring access to justice and ensuring
that people out there who may not be
able to get legal advice won't be
penalized for that if they come back
years down the line as against that
however i can understand entirely people
saying but there needs to be certainty
and there needs to be some principle of
working towards independence within a
defined period of time resolution as an
organization we would like to see
greater clarity in the law to work
towards that who's paid for the wife's
legal fees in this case i mean she says
she's having to travel on buses and
sleep in bus shelters how can she afford
to go to the supreme court that's a very
interesting point and that's something
which had been dealt with in the courts
below in essence in the high court um an
award had been made for the husband to
pay the costs on an interim basis the
court of appeal had said no that's not
fair that can't follow if there's no
realistic prospect of success here why
should he be doing that so that aspect
again has been overturned by the supreme
court today so that along the way her
costs will be funded by the husband by
the husband well whatever happens now
they won't necessarily be taken out of
that settlement if it comes about that
would all be
all be coming out in the wash when the
case goes back as it now will to the
high court
one hesitates to say this but it looks
like the only winners in all this are
the lawyers
well i think it's fair to say the
profession was shocked by this ruling
today and if we don't have divorce
codified in the way that it is in many
countries where you can pretty much feed
in the money and get a formula out at
the end that's absolutely right what we
have here is a very broad discretion in
this country and i know that means that
we are able our judges are able to
tailor their awards and it may well be
people will have to use
the courts more than they would in other
countries that's absolutely the case i
would agree with that and that's been a
criticism that we as a country have been
subjected to and as you may be aware
there was a bill in the house of lords
only last summer in which they said
effectively there does need to be
greater certainty as i've said
resolution as an organization we support
that we think that there should be
greater clarity because what we want is
to see more couples being able to work
out their own solutions by going to
mediation or other forms of dispute
resolution not by having to go through
costly
extensive litigation such as that which
this couple have been through